the Swedish Coast Guard is reporting a
fourth leak in the Nordstrom pipelines
in the Baltic Sea the pipeline usually
ships gas from Russia to Germany Russia
says it's launched a terrorism
investigation over the damage and called
for a meeting of the un's security
Council the EU and NATO say the leaks
were caused by sabotage Nordstrom one is
a key line that transports gas to Europe
but Russia's suspended deliveries
earlier this month because of a standoff
over sanctions Denmark and Sweden first
reported the leagues near the island of
bornholme ships near the lines have been
restricted and Norway is deploying its
military to protect its oil and gas
installations we have two correspondents
covering this story Muhammad Val is
standing by for us in Moscow but first
let's talk two-step vassen she's in SAS
Nets in Germany the port where Nordstrom
deliveries reach land step what more can
you tell us about these reports of
fourth leak and explosions in the lead
up
well what is happening is that the
Swedish Coast Guard is now clarifying
that there was this fourth League
already found on Tuesday two days ago it
was reported then on their website but
somehow never got communicated to the
leaders of the country the Prime
Minister had a press conference the same
day didn't mention it the next day the
head of the Coast Guard had a press
conference also didn't mention it so
it's not a new leak but it was a league
that they detected on Tuesday already
it's a smaller League than the first one
they detected that one was a bit north
of North stream one that's a very big
leak which has a radiation of one square
kilometer coming to the surface this
this gas bubbling up the second one that
they are now reporting is on North
stream too it's a smaller one and then
we have another two leaks on the Danish
side on the Danish economic zone which
is also both one in North stream one and
the other one in North stream too what
we don't know at this ages because both
pipes from nordstrom1 and North stream 2
have consists of two pipes so and
together we are talking about four pipes
if all four of them are now leaking
that's what we don't know for before we
knew that three of them were now damaged
heavily damaged and there was still
torque that one might still be intact
and that's what we don't know we're
still waiting for confirmation to hear
if the fourth one is also badly damaged
we are hearing now reports also the
German intelligence has
suggested that maybe these leaks can't
be repaired at all because what is
happening now is the gas is leaking from
the pipes into the sea and there's
nothing anyone can do to stop it and
then seawater will go into the pipes
there will be corrosion and experts say
this will be very very difficult to
repair
certainly plenty of moving parts to this
story thank you for the update step
vassen live for us there in SAS Nets
Germany
Muhammad Val is live for us in Moscow
now Muhammad how has the Kremlin been
reacting to this news
well my reactions have been streaming
since yesterday and they show the high
level of anger here in Moscow
particularly in the highest spheres of
the government those
accusations we had yesterday that the
Americans are the only one who has the
interest the highest interest in what
happened the talk about
President Joe Biden and that's in the
Press here in official press
made statements very interesting
statements before the war in Ukraine
saying that if Russia's tanks enter
Ukraine there will be no North stream
gas pipelines anymore and he was asked
how that could happen he said there will
be a way to do it this is being
propagated here in Russia and also the
spokeswoman of the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs she reiterated that where those
incidents took place is right at the
heart of the American sphere and the
control of American intelligence in the
Baltic Sea and anything that happens
there is the responsibility of the
United States in a way she also talked
in another in other newsline she talked
about
helicopters images of helicopters that
were spotted U.S helicopters hovering
right over the area where the incidents
took place so in Russia here there is
more and more uh focus on the American
responsibility the potential American
responsibility in these in these uh acts
of sabotage as described here or even
acts of international terrorism against
Russia's interests remember that these
pipelines are perhaps the most strategic
Russian economic card in its economy in
its political games with the European
Partners particularly in the context of
the war in Ukraine the sanctions
couldn't
work a hundred percent against Russia
because the Europeans are in desperate
need for Russian gas so it's a Russia's
trump card has now been destroyed and
they are talking about the amount of
damage already sustained more than 11
billion dollars only in one of the
pipelines and the problem is now when
can this damage be fixed probably never
and that means Russia is now deprived
from its strongest card in the in its
conflict with the West
okay thank you very much for breaking no
damn for us Muhammad Val live for us in
Moscow